cũng đi chứng ra thương mại quán quán yển tới bình truyền mà chết xác thình đại chúng ta như đi ít hơn
chúng ta phải tăng lại xuất thêm, nhưng mà tăng lại xuất đường trong năm 2019.
Bông nghỉ là lại xuất là nụ đó 1,5 bộ với năm 2019.
Thì có lại chứ đi bây giờ thằng chuyến mạc hò, 1 phá để tì bận 1 năm trong tương khu bật con sấu với năm 2019.
Bây nhiên, nếu mà chứng sạc và có 1 tiêu và trong lọc thư đưa ra tròn,
có lại kẻ nè lừa 2, có sẽ cao ở những bạn ăn kì dình kế cấu hình,
kế cấu phần chính phụ trám đăng lực trọng,
kì cấu lè kẻ nè lừa 2, thì kì mạc tầm sống mới làm các bạn nhạc.
Sất xuất.
Cầm như mạc chính xác thình đại chúng ta sẽ không bị ác được lớn.
Bây giờ tối, nhưng mà chúng ta có đi tăng lý hòa tầm năm 2019,
xuất dạm năm 2019, thì tự tin nền là gì đi bây chúng ta thành chứng năm 2019,
bài thằng năm 2019.